[Musica]
tutti noi conosciamo questo oggetto si
prendono due barattoli si collegano con
un filo e io parlo da una parte e mi
sentono dall'altra parte e quanti di voi
l'hanno usato almeno una volta quando
erano piccoli sulle mani Ok dai quasi
tutti ok Io in realtà non l'ho usato
moltissimo però mi ricordo che quelle
volte che l'ho provato restavo
affascinato da come la voce potesse
passare da una parte all'altra tutto
grazie a un sottilissimo filo e pensate
quanto sono rimasto sorpreso quando ho
scoperto che al giorno d'oggi le
comunicazioni avvengono sostanzialmente
allo stesso modo
infatti il 99% di tutti i dati trasmessi
a livello globale passa attraverso i
cavi e non cavi qualsiasi ma cavi lunghi
migliaia a volte decine di migliaia di
chilometri che corrono sui fondali degli
oceani ecco
Questa è una mappa di questi cavi
sottomarini come vedete ci sono tante
linee colorate ciascuna linea colorata è
un cavo Quindi se prendiamo tra gli
Stati Uniti e l'Europa ad esempio vedete
che c'è un cavo arancione Ecco quello
proprio un cavo che collega due
continenti
e torniamo però all'esempio del
barattolo se io decidessi di tagliare
quel cavo che collega i due barattoli
Cosa succederebbe che io parlo da una
parte e dall'altra parte però non mi
sentono più e ancora una volta Questo è
quello che succede anche nella realtà ad
esempio è successo nel 2022 a Tonga che
è un arcipelago in Oceania quando
l'eruzione del vulcano un gattonga unga
a PAI ha tranciato l'unico cavo
sottomarino che collegava l'arcipelago
con il resto della terraferma e quindi
ha isolato da internet tutte le persone
che vivevano sulle Isole per per diversi
giorni in alcune aree Per diverse
settimane Insomma finché non hanno
ripristinato il cavo quindi capiamo bene
come queste Infrastrutture siano
essenziali per connetterci con il resto
del mondo e a volte non se ne parla poi
così tanto quindi credo sia interessante
approfondire un po' torniamo alla mappa
come vi dicevo Questi sono i cavi
sottomarini nel mondo e ce ne sono
5502 per una lunghezza complessiva di
1,4 milioni di chilometri che voi Mi
potreste dire Ma quanti sono tanti sono
pochi è difficile da visualizzare quindi
proviamo a fare un esperimento mentale
Ok immaginate di andare a bordo di un
sottomarino di scendere verso gli abissi
dell'oceano e di raccogliere tutti i
cavi Ok una volta raccolti gli annodiamo
Come fanno nei film detenuti quando
devono scappare no che legano le
lenzuola le annodiamo E questa lunghezza
sarebbe sufficiente per percorrere la
distanza tra la Terra e la Luna per più
di tre volte quindi dalla Terra alla
Luna dalla luna alla terra dalla terra
la luna
e un pezzettino
e questi cavi Però come come funzionano
se noi prendessimo un cavo e lui
tagliassimo quello che vedremo sarebbe
questo
Come direbbe Shrek i cavi sottomarini
sono come le cipolle cioè sono fatti a
strati e senza scendere in dettagli
tecnici possiamo dire che gli strati più
esterni servono per proteggere isolare
il cavo ma noi quello che interessa
veramente è dove vedete quelle lucine
cioè la fibra ottica la fibra ottica
detta in modo molto semplice è un
sottilissimo tubo tubicino all'interno
del quale vengono sparati degli impulsi
luminosi questi impulsi luminosi
rimbalzano sulle pareti di questo
tubicino e quindi percorrono lunghissimi
distanze in pochissimo tempo
di questi cavi abbiamo detto che ce ne
sono tanti ma hanno anche lunghezze
diverse non sono tutti uguali tra di
loro come vedete anche voi dalla
lunghezza delle linee colorate ce ne
sono alcuni alcuni lunghi centinaia di
chilometri altri lunghi migliaia di
chilometri pensate alcuni lunghi anche
decine di migliaia di chilometri anche
20.000 ad esempio e però voi avete non
so 10.000 km di cavo da stendere e come
lo fate come stendete un cavolo lungo
10.000 km non so c'è una bobina
gigantesca che viene srotolata
sull'oceano trattata di mano Chi è per
la parte della bobina gigantesca
Ok qualcuno pochi Bravi avete indovinato
Questa è una nave posa cavi quindi come
suggerisce il nome è una nave che posa i
cavi quindi c'è un enorme bobina la nave
va e lascia cadere dietro di sé il cavo
sottomarino secondo delle rotte
prestabilite quindi i cavi sottomarini
non sono ancorati al fondale sono
appoggiati vengono ancorati e interrati
solo vicino alla terraferma per ragioni
di sicurezza però per il resto sono
proprio appoggiati
per farvi capire un po' meglio come
fatto un cavo immaginatelo grande quanto
una canna dell'acqua da giardino Quindi
all'incirca 2 centimetri e mezzo di
diametro e un chilometro di questi cavi
pesa all'incirca con la tonnellata una
tonnellata e mezza
Ovviamente questa è una delle fasi più
delicate in assoluto perché se voi
sbagliate a scegliere la traiettoria non
so volete mettere un cavolo lungo 5.000
km lo fate passare sul cratere di un
vulcano sottomarino
capite bene che la situazione potrebbe
diventare critica potrebbe rompersi da
un momento all'altro e Pensate che un
cavo può costare dai 30 mila euro in su
per km quindi comunque un investimento
notevole perciò scegliere il percorso
adatto è proprio una delle cose più
importanti in assoluto
abbiamo visto quindi come funzionano
questi cavi Dove si trovano dalla mappa
e dobbiamo rispondere a un'ultima grande
domanda cioè sti cavi di chi sono i cavi
sono inizialmente del produttore che si
occupa anche della messa in posa Dopo di
che Vengono venduti o ad aziende che si
occupano di telecomunicazioni Quindi
quelle che paghiamo per avere internet
sul nostro cellulare oppure a grandi
Player del mondo della Tecnologia come
possono essere non so Facebook oppure
Google
e quindi in questi cavi Come
immaginerete passa un enorme quantità di
dati anche un enorme quantità di dati
sensibili e quindi è possibile
intercettare i dati di un altro paese
per fargli un danno o peggio ancora è
possibile rompere i cavi di un altro
paese per danneggiarlo la risposta è sì
è successo ad esempio il 2013 in Egitto
tre uomini sono stati arrestati proprio
con l'accusa di avere danneggiato
intenzionalmente un cavo sottomarino
causando poi una perdita di dati del 60%
nel paese
ovviamente è una cosa molto complessa
avviene per fortuna raramente Anche
perché voi dovete immaginarvi che è
necessario andare a pescare un cavo
grande quanto una canna dell'acqua da
giardino Dal fondale dell'oceano Queste
sono posizioni indicative quindi non
sono le posizioni esatte quindi voi non
sapete neanche benissimo dove si trova
quindi
è molto complicato non impossibile ma
molto complicato
e a questo punto qualcun altro Allora
potrebbe dirmi Beh ma loro usiamo i
satelliti ce li abbiamo risolviamo tutti
i problemi che normalmente avremmo quei
cavi in realtà i satelliti non li usiamo
li usiamo per trasmettere l'1% di tutti
i dati che vengono appunto trasmessi nel
mondo soprattutto verso aree molto
remote questo perché uno perché i
satelliti al momento costano ancora
troppo e punto 2 perché a livello
proprio di performance Comunque i cavi
sottomarini Al momento sono la nostra
migliore soluzione Ovviamente come
sappiamo tutti La tecnologia va avanti
velocissima cambia di anni un anno
quindi E chissà magari tra qualche anno
sarà tutto quel satellite non ci saranno
più cavi Però al momento questo è la
migliore soluzione che abbiamo
vi ho voluto parlare di questo argomento
perché appunto se ne conosce troppo poco
secondo me ed è veramente interessante
capire cosa c'è dietro l'internet che
usiamo tutti i giorni con i nostri
smartphone e sono sicuro che d'ora in
avanti quando sentirete parlare di Cloud
non penserete a dati che volano nel
cielo ma impulsi di luce sui fondali
oceanici Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]